[Music]
so you've been here for a little while
for years right it's time to send you on
a little business trip this weekend
three days Barcelona I'm going to Spain
well your energy would be perfect for
this what do you mean my energy your
energy your drive your ambition where
are you putting them in quotes because I
mean vagina anyway have fun in Barcelona
bye it's so great I could totally take
the time off and I'm freelance so I'm
totes avail guys this is an important
work trip for me you're not coming
Yeah right off the tail room we can do
whatever the heck we want yeah I just
didn't know it was two beds guys the DJ
he's hot he's amazing Mike he's like a
party man Emily oh nice Anita I'm Harper
are you staying rifle we had like a real
connection listen to me yo man vos isn't
Ibiza tonight I can't just fly to a visa
I have a very important meeting here
tomorrow night this is destiny some
people and other moon oh there's cure
diseases you smashed this DJ yeah
actually that was really impressive in a
good point
if this is as good as this trip gets
this is pretty good I can't stop
thinking about you
this could be my last chance to ever see
him again Harper it's been over 24 Larry
oh you know what might give a [ __ ] meter
is at zero so we're gonna party all
night
hotel rooms are backlight nightmares
there's like residual jizz everywhere
okay I have to suck it up
[Applause]
[Music]